without it we leave the fate of our
world to chance you have no choice all
aboard the Hogwarts Express because
we're about to take you on a journey
behind the scenes of all eight Harry
Potter films the Harry Potter crew loved
using as many practical effects as
possible that's why they had actors
climbing on real piles of furniture in
the room of Requirement and that's why
they spend time building life-size
models of magical creatures like the
basilisk and buck beat so from flying
brooms to breaking wands let's explore
some of the best behind-the-scenes
moments the wand chooses the wizard
every wizard needs a wand and at
Ollivanders the wand chooses you or so
we thought
you would think that the crew did some
cool CGI tricks to get Harry's wand
shopping scene just right but it was
actually done with the help of some
smoke and skillful lighting they brought
a fan on set to aim the smoke exactly
where they wanted for the magical moment
and it cost them a fraction of what it
would have to create the scene digitally
as for the flickering candle that really
sets the mood the team slowed the
footage down to a hundred and twenty
frames per second in post-production to
make it seem like Harry finding his wand
made time move differently Wizarding
chess riding on giant chess pieces is
probably something that you wanted to
try as a kid after seeing the Sorcerer's
Stone
but for Rupert Grint riding a giant
chess piece was a pretty scary reality
since that chess piece was meant to blow
up each piece was actually hand sculpted
for the film and motors were used to
make them move around the board but
since there were kids present they had
to be super careful with how they made
the piece explode they decided that
compressed air was the safest bet so
when Ron sacrifices himself for his
friend and his chest piece explodes it's
actually the compressed air coming out
from within not any crazy CGI tricks
flying lessons
we've all spent a moment wondering how
Harry Potter pulled off those flying
broom scenes and it looks just about as
fun behind the scenes as it does on
screen the cast learned to fly on brooms
attached to rigs that would be
controlled by the crew kind of like
riding a mechanical bull when flying in
a Quidditch match actors would sometimes
have to get on rigs right beside each
other so they could pretend to be flying
for the snitch or avoiding an onslaught
of bludgers hundreds of titanium brooms
ended up being used for the series we
really hope the actors didn't get
nauseous up there because that's a lot
of flying making the house elves it must
be hard to act with someone who isn't
really there that's why the Harry Potter
crew decided to make some quick house
elves on set these makeshift house elves
were made from sticks and tennis balls
so nothing too sophisticated but it got
the job done but after they realized
they would need house elves way more
often they decided that body doubles
would be better they hired actors who
would dress up as the elves and then be
replaced later with CGI it's definitely
a step up from the tennis balls the
basilisk sometimes just knowing where to
look isn't enough especially when it
comes to something as huge as the
basilisk a simple stand-in wouldn't live
up to this huge snake so instead the
Harry Potter crew built a full-scale
aqua Medtronic model that also had
retractable fangs
that's right the snake could move in
water and bite you no wonder Daniel
Radcliffe looks so convincing as he
tries to run away from it another
completely functional accessory was made
for the basilisks hangout the door to
the Chamber of Secrets it was life-size
and really open and we can't even
imagine how cool it must have been to
walk through those epic doors on set
Hagrid's height robbie coltrane who
played Agron had to have been huge to be
casted as a giant right well not so much
while Coltrane is definitely tall about
6 1 he's nowhere near giant height to
make him look taller than all of the
other cast members they decided to hire
a body double martin Bayfield
who towers over Coltrane at 610 who was
chosen for the role
whenever Hagrid was walking with the
kids it was actually BAE fields body in
the frame the
made him a realistic mask so that he
could stand in for Coltrane any time
Hagrid needed a little extra height is
it just us or do you kind of want to
rewatch the entire series just to see if
you notice the difference have you
calmed your hair I have building
Buckbeak
okay so [ __ ] be flying to Azkaban with
Harry and Hermione is definitely done
with some CGI but the Hippogriff isn't
as imaginary as you might think the
actors didn't have to play around with
tennis balls on sticks for this magical
creature a team of 20 designers spent
four months perfecting the Hippogriff
they hand-painted thousands of feathers
from chicken and geese and then glued
them one by one to the animatronic body
the model had moving wings and realistic
eyes and the design team actually ended
up making three different versions of
the mystical creatures but what do you
do with the giant moving Hippogriff once
the movie wraps donate it of course the
realistic Buckbeak can still be seen at
the Harry Potter Studios tour in London
the whomping willow being attacked by an
angry tree doesn't sound like any fun
but filming the whomping willow scenes
makes it look like a blast for the
Prisoner of Azkaban the whomping willow
scene was filmed in front of a green
screen with the camera acting as a
stand-in for the trees branches that's
how we got such cool scenes of Hermione
and Harry diving and ducking to avoid
the tree the actual branches were added
in later with CGI but we have to give to
cast props for looking like they were
realistically avoiding getting throttled
and while the cast wasn't harmed in the
making of these scenes the whomping
willow does have its casualties for the
Chamber of Secrets 14 Ford Anglia's were
wrecked to create the scene where Harry
and Ron crash into the old tree
the second task the tasks for the Goblet
of Fire weren't just a challenge for the
wizards and witches they also required a
lot of hard work and training from the
actors the second task was the hardest
one because the crew had to build a tank
to film the scene the tank was
surrounded by fluorescent tubes to light
the scene from under the water and the
cast members had to learn to hold their
breath for long periods of time while
still acting it took three weeks of
shooting and Daniel Radcliffe spent over
40 hours underwater but he did edit an
underwater cast photo into an epic
Christmas card so safe to say that he
had a pretty good time playing
all d'amour the goblet of fire was ray
Fiennes first Harry Potter film as
Voldemort and it's easy to imagine that
he was covered in prosthetics for most
of it but in reality vines didn't need a
whole lot on his face to look like
Baltimore a few marks were made for
tracking and then they used CGI to add
Voldemort's nose to his face in
post-production
the crew thought it would be quicker to
do it this way since spending time in a
makeup chair to get prosthetics done can
take hours we're not really sure what we
thought Baltimore it had on under his
robes but this definitely wasn't it from
this day forth you put your faith flying
festivals the cast definitely spent a
lot of time up in the air while filming
to ride the mysterious thestrals
the actors would hop on a rig that was
the exact size and shape of a thestrals
midsection then when they were
interacting with the thestrals on the
ground a member of the crew would hold
up a realistic festival head on a stick
so that the actors would know exactly
where to look and touch the biggest
challenge came in post-production when
the VFX artist had to somehow give the
fest rolls all black body some depth so
it wouldn't fall flat on screen Hall of
prophecies the most intense scene in
order of the Phoenix takes place in the
Hall of prophecies a seemingly limitless
room with way too many shelves the
action was filmed on a green screen and
then the maze of shelves was added in
later but the light coming from their
wands was 100% real the cast actually
had battery packs attached to the wands
hidden underneath their clothes but
practical effects aren't always the most
comfortable Daniel Radcliffe said that
these battery packs were heavy and made
using the lumo spell a real pain walking
residential how would you feel if your
house or neighborhood ended up being
featured in a Harry Potter movie
probably pretty cool which is why the
residents of Leacock will Shire in
England were fine with the half-blood
Prince filming on their Street when
Dumbledore and Harry set off to find
Professor Slughorn they walked through
this small residential neighborhood they
filmed the scene between 5:00 p.m. and
5:00 a.m. and had to ask residents to
completely block out their windows both
so they wouldn't see the scene and also
so the set lighting wouldn't keep them
awake at night but most people probably
weren't able to sleep anyway knowing
Harry Potter was a
luring their neighborhood the cave when
Dumbledore and Harry go to the cave to
find and destroy the locket the actors
had to climb and act on realistic rock
formations some were props and some were
real but they were all placed to look
like dangerous jagged rock formations so
that the cast could convincingly
interact with their surroundings never
the conditions on which I brought you
with me this potion might paralyze me
the cave looks pretty small on set
because they digitally expanded the
scene in post-production to make it look
huge the entire background of the cave
and the creepy things living in the
water were added in later with CGI
Gringotts heist it can't be easy to do
goblet makeup on tons of different
actors but for the Gringotts heist seen
in the Deathly Hallows Part 1 the makeup
team had to get ready to make over a
whole bunch of goblins it took 8 months
of preparation to get the makeup and the
practical effects just right but the
Goblin VIP award goes to Warwick Davis
Davis spent hours and makeup every day
he was on set and the makeup artist
spent even more time making sure Davis
as many characters didn't all look
exactly the same the wand breaker
Ron Weasley isn't the only wizard with a
habit of breaking wands throughout the
entire Harry Potter series
Daniel Radcliffe was responsible for
breaking about 81 but how did he
accidentally break so many props while
he loved using the wands as drumsticks
which definitely could have been part of
it he also really liked poking his other
cast mates with them which probably
explains why so many broke in half but
considering he's the star of the
franchise we're sure the prop Department
didn't mind making him a few extras
Harry's fate most people know that Alan
Rickman was told how Snape story would
end early by JK Rowling but so was
Daniel Radcliffe Rowling told him before
the last book was published that Harry
would lose his life in one particular
scene in the final movie so Daniel
Radcliffe knew before we did that Harry
would have an epic resurrection not that
we're surprised Rowling would tell him
before us the author and the star have a
pretty good friendship that they've kept
going over the years the Room of
Requirement the Room of Requirement is
one of the most complex sets in the
Harry Potter films it became even more
complex in the Deathly Hallows part-2
when the cast had to
why mountains of furniture as the crew
literally set fire to the stage the set
was built with hundreds of actual props
fitted to scaffolding and tied to
supports so that the actors could climb
to set with harnesses the major flames
were added in later with CGI but the
crew used torches to light small fires
all over the set to make the action look
more realistic Voldemort's speech ray
Fiennes isn't just good at pulling off
Voldemort's the signature robes he also
has a way with words which is why his
speech at the end of the Deathly Hallows
part-2 was partially improvised and a
little bit different every time he gave
it the director wanted the speech to
feel authentic so he let Fiennes have
some fun with it
this was also the first time Valda Moore
was meeting Neville and it was the first
time Fiennes was acting with Matthew
Lewis even though they'd already
technically starred in five Harry Potter
films together
Rupert's strange gifts saying goodbye
isn't easy and it's even harder when
you've worked on eight films together
through your childhood but to lighten
the mood Rupert Grint decided to give
his on-screen besties some unique
presence he gave both Emma and Daniel
trumpets as parting gifts and no neither
actor played the instrument Rupert and
Emma also worked together to bring
Rupert's ice cream truck to set on the
last day of filming so that the entire
cast could have a sweet treat before
saying goodbye
which behind-the-scenes secrets
surprises you most do these onset
moments ruin the magic for you or do
they just make it that much more
impressive let us know what you think in
the comments don't forget to hit that
like button and subscribe to the things
for more thanks for watching and we'll
see you next time
you